congratulations you got a lot going on
in your life what's happening
uh i just had a baby well well uh
my fiance olivia just had a baby yeah
you you did
very little there she did the work
probably seven weeks ago
uh february 15th her name is zoe douglas
forte
we love her and uh she was delivered by
a doctor named dr rad dr
rad dr rad r-a-d that's is that
his real name is dr rad yeah i mean he
might have had it you know maybe it was
dr radical
and he you know
he's a wonderful doctor but you can call
me dr
rad that's fantastic
and he was he's a good doctor i guess
he's a great doctor he did everything
that needed to be done and
and uh the baby's doing great and and
uh you know of course you get home and
you're getting
tons of of uh gifts from people
baby gifts people are sending food but
by far
the best gift that i got uh you know i'm
a 50 year old
father which is pretty old for uh father
so my
family olivia had this made for me
um your fiance had this a sweatshirt
that says
dad or grandpa
[Laughter]
you're right on the line it could go
either way i've been this
this has touched off basically like all
the all the kind of
i mean i have a lot as you probably are
aware i'm a weird dude and and
have a lot of weird things about me but
but like i've one of the
problems i have is is i'm kind of a pack
rat
and i uh kind of i got way better about
it but then
this has just reignited uh you know
having
having this daughter has reignited
everything because i'm like i gotta i
gotta save
everything oh because everything's a
first you know what i mean that's the
thing
like so you feel sentimental about it
right yeah
exactly so i i you know in the hospital
it's gotten
so deep that it's like i i after her
first
poop i was like i gotta gotta save this
diaper right
and my fiance is like you're super gross
there's no way we're saving the diaper
so i finally
convinced her like oh but it make what
if we like saved it
to give as a good practical joke to a
friend to a close
a close friend and she said you know
begrudgingly
agreed that it would be a good joke to
to give somebody as a present
and then of course i got home and i was
like okay well maybe we should just keep
it for our files so we do have
we do have it's it's in a specimen oh
for god's sake why do you
have that that's terrible
no this is what if she what if she
somehow becomes
you know the first president of mars
this is for that museum no no no they're
not gonna want that you gotta get you
gotta get rid of that that's
they don't want that then maybe they'll
want her umbilical cord oh for god's
sake
that's it you saved the umbilical cord
yeah you know what you can oh what's
your baby i also saved her baby
okay well the baby hat makes sense but
you don't want to know what's inside the
baby well
i'm guessing nothing's inside the baby
um
the umbilical cord you know what you can
do you can have it
uh put into jewelry did you know that
and wear it around your neck
you can have it you know put in like
some kind of glass or something and wear
it around your neck that's what you can
do
or i could poke holes in it myself and
just put a little string around it and
wear around
my neck for probably a way less of a
charge
right yeah it would cost less but it
would rot off of
your you know very quickly oh okay i
do want to save it uh you know the um
we went on a terrible cul-de-sac there
and i apologize to everybody a horrible
dad oh man i'm gonna be the most
embarrassing
yeah it's terrible like here's her first
tear we made her cry on purpose so we
could save it
uh you know i would think now during
kovid and
you know it feels like we're leaving
this covid period i hope
knockwood but uh it's still we have
still have to be careful
so i would think right now baby photos
are more important than ever because you
can't have family
visit and see the baby so you've gotta
you gotta send out that baby photo that
is crucial right now
oh yeah yeah the the uh i
i was kind of in charge of getting all
the pictures sent out i had a
text change of various people but but
the main text chain was obviously to
to my my family and i got in
a little bit of trouble um because at
some point
i i have a phone that is
has served me well but one of my dogs uh
knocked it out of my hand and so it had
a bunch of
squiggly you see all the squiggly lines
there on the side
oh it's got some it's got some yeah it
looks like cracks or something on it
yeah
yeah i mean it that just kind of
permanently showed up and wouldn't go
away and this was my fault the phone is
a you know it's a fine
phone i'm not doing an ad for a phone
but but like it was my fault the lines
showed up so i couldn't
i couldn't see everything they would you
know
so so there's one picture that i found
of my fiance
that was just the it was so delightful
and uh her and the baby
as you can see oh she's right there yeah
what a beautiful photo that's very
beautiful yeah well what i wasn't aware
of
was that hidden behind these white lines
over here
was just her completely full nipple
oh my god and i sent that to
my mom and my dad my uh
brother-in-law my sister my niece and
nephew who are
like 11 and 10 laney and alden yeah
well i've done to you well hold on and
then you had it made into a giant
cardboard cutout
and you're holding it up right now to me
you freak
what are you doing this this that
foreign to be part of the umbilical cord
necklace i'm going to wear it around my
nipple
so basically yeah you sent uh your
your fiance's nipple out to a bunch of
young teens
is what you did unknowingly and she
she is a wonderful fiance because she
was like oh
you know i guess i guess everybody who
goes through
childbirth if you have not been
desensitized to having your nipples
uh out in public then you you kind of
get to that point yeah and she's there
but she was very
a very good sport about it uh well yeah
i'm glad i'm happy for you
that you've your relationship is still
going strong